hi
you must be liam hey buddy how are you
feeling today
i'm feeling fine dr gupta
just fine this is miriam glass
and she's from the make-a-wish
foundation marian glad
how are you feeling today liam
i'm fine mary in glass
good well i have some news that might
make you feel a little better
huh we at the make-a-wish foundation
make dreams come true
for little boys and little girls who are
very sick
just like you there are no children
like me mary in glass
of course not you're one of a kind but
we're gonna make
any dream come true that you could ever
have okay
anything that's right buddy that's right
would would you like to play with your
favorite basketball team
what about being superman for a day i
wish
to drown a man
[Music]
what to drown a man in the bathtub
to hold him down while the last breath
escapes his body
and then
liam you said anything
surely we don't want to hurt other
people now do we you know
any anything else fly in a hot air
balloon or
meet a celebrity my new wish
is to lean over the body of a dying man
and put my lips on his
stealing his last breath
liam no one will get hurt no
absolutely not i don't even know where
you
i wish to take all the prosthetic legs
in the hospital
and bind them together with
the dried flesh of the dead into a
webbed massive creature
liam i am so sorry
miss claus it's all right he he doesn't
know what he's saying
i wish to pee in your mouth what both of
you
mine especially you oh
i wish to pee in both of your mouths
as i stand over you i'll need a glass of
water in ten minutes
enough you little dr gupta no
you're reprehensible you are evil
you are a devil child
dr gupta he's not a devil child he's
just a child
you have no business working in a
pediatric ward what i'm gonna report you
shame on you
[Music]
shame on
this is insane
you've made me question everything that
i've ever believed about
the essential goodness of the children
wish granted
[Music]
i am
[Music]
you